-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing
well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to The News.
The FDA announced today
that it will ban the sale
of JUUL e-cigarettes.
In related news,
some 15-year-olds
just breached the Capitol.
[ Laughter ]
The Supreme Court today issued
several rulings,
including one that overturns a
New York state gun law
restricting concealed weapons.
So move over, tourists.
Seriously, move over,
'cause you're gonna get shot.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, the Supreme Court
overturned a New York law.
A New York state gun law
restricting concealed weapons,
'cause, you know, when sometimes
you'll be on the "F" train
in August and there's no AC.,
and then it stops
in the middle of the tunnel
and the conductor
doesn't announce anything.
And you think to yourself, "Man,
I wish we all had guns."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
the Biden administration
got in touch with Tesla for
advice on electric car policy
despite President Biden's public
feud with Elon Musk.
Yeah, Biden's not afraid to
hash it out
with someone
he disagrees with.
He still thinks he can be
friends with Mitch McConnell.
Hell, just yesterday,
he had lunch with that bike.
[ Laughter ]
I wondered all day, "How does a
bike sit at a table?"
And that's -- that's the best
possible way to do it.
Media mogul Rupert Murdoch
is reportedly divorcing
his fourth wife,
model Jerry Hall.
Wow. That's his fourth wife?
Who is his first wife, Eve?
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump is
reportedly
planning to visit Alaska
next month.
So get ready for that
stream of consciousness.
[ As Trump ] "It's so good to be
in Alaska, which is not
connected to the other states.
Many people don't --
many people don't know that.
Very, very unfair of the
mainland.
The way they treat Alaska is
very unfair.
It's very -- home of Juneau.
Juneau.
That wacky high school girl who
got pregnant."
[ Laughter ]
"She said silly words.
She talks in a very --
A very silly way, Juneau.
We love Juneau.
We love --
And that, my friends, is
everything I know about you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] The makers of
Monopoly yesterday
released a Hamptons Edition of
the board game.
Said residents,
"What the hell is income tax?"
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Oklahoma arrested
an employee at a fast-food
restaurant this week
after a customer found
a small bag of
crystal meth with their order,
when they had clearly ordered
a large!
[ Laughter ]
The U.S. Patent and Trademark
Office officially approved
a request yesterday for
Ohio State University
to register the word "the" in an
attempt to get
your dad to stop calling it
"The Facebook."
[ Laughter ]
Finally, tomorrow is national
"Take your dog to work day,"
while for people
who work from home,
it's national
"Work around your cat day."
[ Laughter ]
And that, you guys,
was the monologue, everybody.